[Music]  which priorities should the EU finance  in the future  members will quiz the Commission on its  long-term budget proposals Belgian Prime  Minister shall Michel takes his turn to  debate Europe's future before the  European Parliament following a European  band members are urging the Commission  and EU governments to take action to end  animal testing in the cosmetics industry  around the world on the 5th of may  Parliament in Brussels will open its  doors to the public across the EU  thousands of people will take part in  debates and festive events to celebrate  Europe day how can migrant children be  better protected Parliament is pushing  for measures to ensure their rights  health care and education are respected  [Music]